thank you to all of my supporters on
patreon
synthesizers as digested by a classical
musician
just kidding
[Music]
that's also not quite what i'm getting
at
[Music]
i want to know how synthesized sounds
can enhance augment and at times stand
in place of traditional acoustic sounds
in the context of contemporary music
wow there's so many ways you could dial
this if you turn up the resonance really
high
[Music]
coming from a classical music background
i've been less exposed to digital sounds
until quite recently so much of this
exploration deals with familiarizing
myself with different types of
synthesizers and how different types of
sounds are created
the instrument i'm working on is the
cp88 and full disclaimer here it was
sent to me by yamaha when i moved to new
york city recently and for now it's the
only keyboard i have to work on so
naturally the instrument itself started
influencing things i was writing
good morning
so
i am ready to work
later on you'll hear how i turn this
little musical idea
[Music]
into the spinal piece
[Music]
but first i want to share with you the
process i went through with the help of
some of my friends to open my eyes and
ears to new types of instruments and
synthesized sounds
oh i like how it it's just kind of
dissolved it
let's see where this goes
my friend james khan showed me some
vintage synthesizers
[Music]
it's like it's like having a pipe organ
but from the future
while hanging out with my friend adam
nealy we experimented with an analog
synthesizer so there's a little bit of
noise here
i kind of like the noise
just
and my friend andrew huang showed me a
bunch of things about modular
synthesizers
yeah so 47 of the time it's going to
skip
actually sending out the trigger
it's a five beat
cycle four of the beads are
possible but 47 of the time it will not
send one of those beats
these experiences all shaped a new
understanding and appreciation i have of
timbre texture and rhythm in relation to
sound design
and then pitch is like
[Music]
a hilarious vibrator
can express myself finally
this is this is
the sound that you want
that's a guitar that doesn't sound like
guitar
[Music]
keep it on that sound i'm gonna
just real briefly i'm gonna connect the
subwoofer
[Music]
i like this kind of
like that that like
clipping normally like
i try and
avoid that avoid that but it kind of
it's kind of cool in this context
so this is the uh
oh the super low end
yeah
it's that's that sub bass is like it's
like those
cars that go by and you're like oh okay
but then
i can do that now
yeah so you can play that but and then
you see there's nothing below it and
what are those others oh this this is
the noise noise floor so if you just it
will always have that actually you know
what we gate that so we don't have
like
that
sound
so it's kind of like just more of a sine
wave but that sound right there works
really well with the stuff
this is the way we could do it we can
have the random voltages generated at
the same rate as these kick drum rhythms
when you apply it to a parameter so if
we apply it to the
pitch of that
every time there's a kick drum it
changes the note of the kick drum i
really like that
it's not regular yeah yeah
[Music]
i don't like the sound but i like the
what i find is
newer relative to the whole you know
history of music is an appreciation for
timbre that's now possible
when we're able to create so many new
ones electronically
oh cool
[Music]
yeah
all right cool
and then i get bored of it
[Music]
okay i get it
got it
done
so i did learn quite a bit about the
different types of waveforms and how
different types of effects are employed
using synthesizers but the main takeaway
for me could be summed up with these
words dial to taste like how much you
want that style to taste yeah i feel
like that is
what describes synthesizers
[Music]
there's adsr attack decay sustain
release and that's how you make sounds
so that's when the sound stops
if you have a hop there
it's going to keep going until you shut
the machine off
so
that's the saw
triangle
square
they're just like that's that's like the
building blocks of each one of these
there's so many different types of
synthesizers that work in so many
different ways but i've gathered that
they are all tools for basically the
same thing the ability to design and
craft a specific sound to portray a
specific color emotion and atmosphere
with your musical ideas
oh it's so high we might want to tune
those down
[Music]
oh i've never even got it to do this
before it's really kind of like broken
feeling yeah
again as somebody who is not trained in
any of this just trying to get by it
feels like it's a lot more about how you
design the sound of a note
rather than how you design
the patterns of notes because the
patterns of notes could be very simple
right but the design of that one note
could be very complicated
[Music]
oh that's interesting
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i think i'm
afraid of heights
all of these things fed into how i
wanted to form my piece and after coming
up with that initial idea i did a loose
improvisation session around it and
ended up transcribing a portion of it to
get my composition going
[Music]
okay
so
i had some good ideas
some very questionable ones i also had a
visual reference that i personally used
to map out the types of rhythmic and
harmonic progressions i imagined for the
piece and this is what that looked like
so similar to
how some of these smaller lines kind of
sprout out of
areas like this or here basically the
staggered and irregular nature of the
lines represents the irregularity of the
rhythmic patterns i use as well as how i
want the harmony to move at times
a lot of this had to do with the
influence i got from hearing irregular
patterns generated on the modular
synthesizers when i was hanging out with
andrew
while writing my piece i was very much
influenced by the prospects of being
able to design a sound catered to each
type of idea i had and layering
different sounds that were available to
me i took my time in finding what types
of combinations i wanted for each
section and quite frankly after a bunch
of experimentation i found that using a
small amount of extra sounds worked the
best rather than excessively using the
options available
so i like how this setting sounds with
[Music]
something like a perfect fifth
without
[Music]
just adds a little bit of a almost like
a halo over
these notes so
[Music]
i thought that was cool if you compare
that with
it's a lot more interesting
for this sound i find that layering it
with the piano is actually a lot more
interesting than hearing it by itself
this sounds
i don't know not great to me but with
the piano
i just like that combination of course i
could also see the pros and cons of
using an acoustic piano versus a
keyboard and inevitably did some
comparisons
[Music]
you know i actually quite like these
transitions on the piano
[Music]
i can play really
soft and
place off
comfortably
requires the
piano i think as keyboard players
it's always a good thing to be able to
adjust to different keyboards different
types of pianos
really fast because
that's just the nature of the reality
for us do you find this easier to fire
off with the fingers
no you prefer the weight yeah you'd
rather fight the weight you're not
fighting it just it's um
you're in touch with the keys when
you're when there's weight okay and it's
almost like you're
riding the resistance
whereas with this it feels like you're
kind of skating on something
slippery this keyboard this particular
one
is quite heavy
compared to other ones
it's weighted and
there is
organic material there's wood in between
the keys which
really makes a difference
but still there's something about
the type of resistance here that is
not familiar to me and
quite different from an acoustic
instrument the solution there is just to
practice i found that just
spending time with this keyboard i was
able to
feel a lot more comfortable with those
differences
and
what else
i think that's it another huge thank you
to james adam and andrew for helping me
out and to yamaha for supplying me with
the keyboard now here's the final piece
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
i hope this video gave you all some
ideas for your own musical explorations
and thank you so much for watching
looking at this i feel like my life is
together
also this is the type of sound
i don't like like the 80s like yeah that
sort of thing
all right you're putting me on the spot
what do i do hold on that's what i want
okay